So here in the state of Georgia and across
the nation, quite frankly, there's a concerted
effort being undertaken by Republicans, um,
to create the scenario to, um, have a case
go all the way to supreme, to the Supreme
Court that will ultimately Undo Roe versus
Wade.
I'm sure David has covered this and, uh, it's
all over the news, so you already know what's
going on.
But there's been an interesting twist in this
story.
Prosecutors in Georgia, as well as Missouri.
Uh, and in Utah have stated that they will
not prosecute women underneath this law according
to business insider.com.
Um, and also Alabama of all states.
There is a prosecutor in the state of Alabama
who's also said that, uh, they will not, um,
prosecute any women under these laws.
I want to read a quote from the article.
Uh, Chris Hopper, director of public affairs
for the Fulton County District Attorney's
office told 11 alive and Lube News that the
DA quote has no intention of ever prosecuting
a woman under this new law.
While Gwinnett county's district attorney,
Danny Porter said, this office will not be
prosecuting any women under the law as on
an a new law as long as I'm districted attorney
now Gwinnett and Fulton counties, our counties
right here in the state of Georgia.
Uh, and apparently I believe Cobb County,
uh, decab county as well as Cobb county has
also said that they will not be prosecuting
anyone underneath these laws.
Now, I find it a fascinating, we often forget
that, um, district attorneys have discretion
and they can execute that discretion.
Um, that becomes a very interesting topic
when you think about all the other things
they choose to prosecute people for.
But we'll take our wins, how we can get them.
I think it's a, a, a fascinating and a very
significant way for people to resist.
Like this is actual resistance.
This is using your power, using your position
to effect change against laws that you see,
um, that, that are unconstitutional for one,
um, and laws that are really meant, um, to
be implemented in the most draconian fashion
imaginable.
Um, I want to read one more quote from the
article.
It says, quote, there is no language out long
outline and HB 41 that's the law here.
Um, in Georgia, explicitly prohibiting a district
attorney from bringing criminal charges against
anyone and everyone involved in obtaining
and performing what is otherwise currently
a legal medical procedure as decided by the
United States Supreme Court opinion and precedent
precedent.
This is coordinated decab county district
attorney Sheri Boston on Associates said in
a statement, um, this is, this is very important
and very significant because there's, there's
not many things that can be done in the states
when these states are controlled by a Republican
majority in their state house and their state
senate and you have a Republican, uh, empower.
This is literally the last line of defense
for a woman's right to choose and, you know,
setting the, the particulars of the story
of side, uh, and, and getting more into the
strategy at hand.
Right.
This has always been the strategy of the Republican
Party since 1973 since roe versus wade was
decided on by the Supreme Court.
Republicans have put and conservatives more
specifically have put a plan and a strategy
in motion.
I mean, think about that.
That's a 46 year plan that they have set in
motion because I don't know how many people
point this out, but Alabama, uh, Georgia particularly,
they have had republican majorities in their
State House, state senate, and in their a
and a Republican in the governor seat to sign
their legislation.
They've had those majority's for for some
time, right?
It's been probably generations, uh, a solid
generation or two since there's been a Democrat
in power, um, in the state of Georgia and
Alabama.
And more specifically the, the, the specific,
uh, party name doesn't matter as much as the
ideology, but there has probably never been
in, in a good generation, two or three a progressive
or a liberal empower in these states.
And the reason I bring that up, it's significant
because you see that they waited until 2019
they waited to this specific moment to implement
this strategy.
Why?
That's because Donald Trump has a conservative
majority on the bench.
This is always been about waiting until they
could strike and strike the most effectively.
They're getting this into a situation.
They're creating a scenario where this case
has to go to the Supreme Court and there was
no other time before right now then that they
could have gotten in the decision in their
favor.
And so now they believe that with, uh, the
appointment of a Brett Kevin know that they
will be able to overturn roe versus Wade.
This is so significant to understand and understand
clearly because Republicans play the long
game.
They've been waiting on this and working on
this for almost 46 years and now they're opportunity
has come and they're seizing upon it.
That's why you're seeing state after state
after state passed some of these laws.
And right now the only, the last line of defense,
the only thing that's going to keep women
from getting prosecuted our doctors from being
prosecuted for performing abortions owner,
then it's going to stop, uh, um, a woman's
choice to get an abortion at all.
Really are these prosecutors who are come
out and coming out and saying that they will
not prosecute anyone underneath this law.
The real question now becomes how long would
they, uh, these particular prosecutors have
maintained their seats?
Um, once it becomes clear to the public that
they are going to actually do this,
that remains
to
be seen.